[Music]
as a parent
you guys uh how do you guys feel
about or like do you guys have you guys
ever talked about how to
um address like the female body and like
uh feminism
and like uh just kind of like what's
what the healthy perspective of how to
view a woman body
uh in terms of like in the day you guys
will you know talk to tyka about it
um i usually go hey turkey see your mom
i bang her and she's mine
no he's kidding um and he's like
like i've already done i'm already
trying to do stuff like that
uh not even like intentionally but i
think just because i'm a woman
and like i know like this is food my
body yeah like i'll just say like oh
like mom like this is mommy's chest and
it hurts you know
like like so i'll just already start
doing little things like that all right
that's good
or or like i'll point out how him and
his dad are the same but like i'm
different because we'll like be naked if
we're showering or we're like changing
or whatever
i see um and he finds it just hilarious
because it's so different and like you
can see when it's like he's lappy
you don't gotta die
he'll look at his and it'll be like oh
daddy's butt butt and then like he'll
say like my butt like
he'll grab his dick and he goes but
that's not your butt
ew because he's just like it's yeah
cause it's just not like his or his
dad's
um but stuff like that like i try to
like show him like oh no like my mommy
should hurts like it'll hurt and then he
goes daddies and i'm like no
is this what you're just uh doing or did
you like learn about that
too uh no i didn't learn about [ __ ] when
you're just teaching them like your
style your own way yeah how you feel and
thinking exactly because i'm like he's
gonna interact with females
uh so like i'm already teaching him
differences
and also just kind of like being aware
of like some of these differences
you know i'm like uh like these areas
are sensitive and then i'll just like
i've already been teaching him like
people shouldn't be touching him there
and sometimes he mixes that up because
then he tells us not to touch him while
we're changing his diaper and we're like
oh [ __ ] like how do i stop that right
but they're just in public
don't touch my butt don't touch it
we're just changing this diaper we're
like you don't say it out loud
mommy and daddy and grandma and grandpa
can't touch it and i'm like oh [ __ ] i
shouldn't say that either so it's like a
weird
you know it's like a weird space but i'd
rather go the extreme for now
uh you're changing his diaper and he's
like don't touch my baby yeah
don't touch it i'm like i have to monkey
like i always call monkey i'm like i
have the monkey you have like poo poo or
whatever you know
yeah yeah so that's because he's only
two so you can't really get too
complicated with things right right
yeah it's true with isaac like i think i
missed out on that phase where i think
tiff was able to
like you know start at an earlier age
right so
it just blows my mind like in terms of
how you educate uh
children about like the differences of
our bodies and stuff like that and like
kind of like just having a more healthy
concept of that right you gotta teach
them everything that's crazy you gotta
program everything well because when i'm
talking to him i'm always trying to talk
to him as
uh like with with the thought of he's
gonna be older someday
and then also going like damn these are
some things i wish my parents would have
prepped me on
so i'm always when i'm talking to him
i'm always trying to at least
to think of like the future interactions
that he'll have
it's hard man it's [ __ ] hard we peed
in the shower the other day together
yeah they try to aim for the because
we're trying to like because i think
we're trying to like learn how to uh
uh potty train them and transition so
the first thing is
getting him to understand that he could
actually control his pee
because he's just plain to just pee in
his diaper so he doesn't see what's
happening when he's peeing in his diaper
so he doesn't even know so you have to
actually get up to
the first time he saw it he was just
like what is happening
like when he's running around outside in
the backyard he just started peeing he's
like
yeah he got scared he was naked yeah
yeah and then so
now we can i can get him like okay we're
in the shower we're going to pee
together
why we start [ __ ] too in the shower
[Laughter]
no he's like one two three we start
peeing we start aiming for the hole so i
think once i could get him to aim and
then to like
understand i compete when i want then we
could probably slowly transition that to
the toilet
that's true because if you think about
like just humans in general we weren't
so covered up
back in the day like and if like i had a
kid i'd just go pee and then he would
watch
that and then go oh yeah mine's like
dead it's normal life yeah it's like
that approach yeah so in india
a youtuber uh like influencer person
has been arrested this is uh rihanna
fatima right anna
fatima i didn't know rihanna was an
indian name that's so cool that's true
um yeah so she is she has a youtube
channel and she has like 40 000 on ig
she's in india and she does a lot of you
know feminism
uh work in terms of you know expressing
what the female body
is and like the idea that it's you know
i guess not healthy in terms of how
with the current state of how men view
it and all that so she's a very
she's very she's been very vocal at
least in the news from
india that comes out that we hear at
least on this side of what happens to
women in india there's a lot of
oppression over there that's true so
she's fighting a fight that's very very
uh against her yes exactly so she's been
arrested now because she released a
video
where she had her kids and her kids are
like a little older i would say
like definitely not infants you know
like and they're
she's topless in this video and they're
painting on her body
and so a son and a daughter and when
this video came out
it was reported to the authorities in
india and she was apprehended
and she has she cannot be released on
bail so they're taking it very very
seriously
under what charge probably pornography
yeah so like yeah like basically
indecent exposure type stuff like
sexually explicit imagery
transmitted electronically and also
involving children
i don't know if that would even fly here
it probably wouldn't fly here
because it's not like we could take a
shower with taika and then film it and
then send it
yeah you can't take film yourself
showering and send it i don't know yeah
i don't know i know you could upload a
video
being topless on youtube if it's not
scientific and breastfeeding
i think if it's painted then it's
covered yeah it's like art
yeah i think this would this would fly
here it would
oh maybe i just did maybe maybe from
here how it is it looks like
it looks like it's very like blocked
though like it's like there's like paint
brushes like strategically placed
like that where it blocks the nipple and
then probably even here people would be
weird
with like like she said having like kids
in a video a while you're naked
with the actual like intent of it you
know not even the
educational part of it but it's like if
it's not for like
pornographic reasons i think and just
consider art like
then it's like was like kids that uh or
like other countries that
they're not so like women have to cover
up like that or
it's like so bad to show boobs or
whatever
so i think here it's like we're kind of
like against that or in america it's
like don't show your boobs that's
yeah because if you did this in like
europe europe oh yeah they'd be
cool with france would be chill yeah i
don't know if they'd be cool when
there's kids involved
because i'm not sexualizing this so for
example right like
if i don't know i had like a nephew and
i was
painting on his face or whatever and
then they're painting on me and then
like
it's fine or whatever you know painting
on my dick might be weird but at the
same time
there's also the closeness that you have
that's different if you if you have a
bathing culture
like if if i grew up bathing with my
family
like back in japan like that's normal
right and
you do funny [ __ ] like that all the time
within boys
it depends on the culture so yeah in
this context
it's probably really [ __ ] taboo in
what they're doing
but also i don't see this as it's
sexualized yeah
i think that's where it's her own
children too yeah
i just think they're just painting thing
and they're making their it's just the
body part you know
america's weird about this [ __ ] though
america's way more afraid of sex than
like any other pedophilia right now is
like which i'm happy that everyone is
very alert and aware uh so everyone is
always looking
at things from a different lens that's
true yeah but then again with this it's
not
pedophilia it's no but i think uh your
idea is everyone's
lenses everyone's everyone's
hypersensitive hypersensitive
the mom is a pedophile no everyone's
hypersensitive with pedophilia
yeah i get that but it's also like in
this context you can't say it's like
pedophilia well context doesn't matter
when people are hypersensitive
that's the thing and then the idea is
too it's like you release this footage
out to the public
the public can take this now and do
whatever it wants with it you know like
some some pedo out there can take this
and be like
oh i could jerk off of this you know
whatever but it's the reason i'm not
saying is that because they could then
jerk off because the kids aren't getting
naked
their kids aren't doing i don't think
we're saying it's pedophilia but no i
know i know
i'm saying in terms of like the context
of like because their minds are so crazy
that they're already doing something
weird but
it's the mother and the adult doing the
the showing that and if you want to look
at it in a sexual way
i don't see how like someone that
sexualizes kids can see that
for the sexualization of kids i see
where you're getting at but i think like
the overall
imagery i think if you're hypersensitive
it's just kids and pornography
yeah it's very provocative so it's
almost like a kid painting a man's penis
like it's like
because i i guess people would equate
that you know like painting the mom's uh
nipples and breasts versus like painting
a man's penis like it just
it's like close to the line so i can see
i think that's hilarious
like yeah like okay this is a funny
image
to me because i'm not sexualizing it i
can't because my mind doesn't work this
way right
but imagine your friends
are making an elephant painting on your
dick
there's a chinese movie like that i
don't know if you've ever watched oh
yeah they're little kids
so there's these two monks yeah i see
them yeah there's these two monks and
then that's why like like the the the
culture and the sexual culture like
from like asian content or even
countries it's just it's just different
right like
in asian movies there's so many movies
where they show like little kids like
dick dicks and they they're like peeing
and [ __ ] i'm like and it's like a
close-up of it they don't think it's
sexualized when it's
underage yeah like so for example
there's a anime
uh cartoon show called shinchan um and
there's a kid that like this is a kids
show that we grew up watching
and he would repeatedly draw an elephant
ear around his dick and he would
run around the house and [ __ ] chase
his mom and shake
and that's literally normalized it's not
sexual it's just pranking it's just
whatever right
and for me i think it's even weirder
in america and in judeo-christian
culture we're
so ashamed of the human body to the
point where everything is sexualized i
think that's weird
the movie i'm talking about it's live
action this is two
kids dick on a live action one of them
fights kung fu the other one's a fan
yeah two buddhist monks it's almost like
this is like almost like kind of like
rush hour like one kid
is really good at martial arts the other
one is a goo he's he's like
a chubbier kid he's really goofy and
loves to eat every single dessert
they come out of the monk they come out
of the uh the shaolin monk i'm in the
shaolin temple
and then um they're trying to assimilate
and for some reason the chubbier kid
that loves to eat desserts loses all his
clothes and all he has is sunglasses on
so now so he meets like one of those
street painters and they're like don't
worry i'll cover you up so they paint an
elephant on his dick and
his dick is the trunk and now the whole
movie he's
walking around going like this eating
like donuts and stuff while his other
buddy is like kicking everyone's ass
that's the whole movie why does it
almost feel like kung fu hustle there's
also the fat kid
has come for hustle bye yeah yeah yeah
see that's funny
i don't know and and to me it's so
difficult to look at that
and maybe because i'm not a pedophile i
can't even desire that or see that in
any way yeah right so then
maybe the people that are watching that
and they're going like hey
like that's turning me on we need to ban
this or they're just like thinking
what about the pedophiles that might use
this and jack off to it
yeah i think it's like protecting it's
like protected
or whatever you have to what if yeah
yeah that makes sense it's
really much of that like slippery slope
argument yeah yeah just taking things
too far
so what's gonna happen to this lady i
don't know it's kind of still ongoing
she's in jail right now
uh uh section 67
at the i.t act i don't know whatever
that is uh which is like electronically
transmitting sexually
explicit content uh and she's being um
held uh no no uh
no bail and then it's the party that is
really against her right now it's called
the ba
tia janata party it's the conservative
party in india
yeah so it's definitely it's a political
thing for sure
and you you don't know what the porn
laws are out there either because
it might be like no porn or like no
nudity no nudity
yeah yeah that's true
[Music]
you